[Musique]
bonjour je suis ATIS barré donc
conseillère municipal à la ville de
poissie et aujourd'hui nous sommes donc
en mairie nous sommes venus voir les
agents de la ville de poissie qui ont le
privilège de pouvoir travailler avec
leurs chien nous allons voir Nathalie
qui est aujourd'hui en compagnie de
tolby bonjour Nathalie bonjour Toby tu
dis bonjour Toby tu dis bonjour Merci
Toby nous accueillir
[Musique]
ça a beaucoup changé au niveau de du
midi pour le sortir et tout ça c'est
vrai que je cours moins mais et puis ben
c'est c'est quand même plaisant d'avoir
son petit compagnon avec avec soi au
travail ça me ça m'a fait du bien bon il
a un petit peu peur il est un petit peu
craintif mais il a il AP il a il s'est
beaucoup amélioré depuis depuis qu'il
vient avec
moi Toby est bien installé donc elle a
ses croquettes son eau elle est bien au
frais voilà elle a son petit coussin
voilà ses petits jouets ah ouais
Toby
[Musique]
sympa nous allons aller au service
communication de la Ville de poissie
nous allons à la rencontre de deszy qui
vient travailler avec Julien allons les
voir bonjour Julien bonjour coucou DESY
ça va comment ça a changé ton quotidien
ouais bah ça a tout changé hein les
vient quiment chaque jour ici ouais et
on a pris nos petites
habitudes nos petites habitudes
quotidiennes donc là elle fait le tour
du service dit bonjour à tout le monde
ouais parfois même eux oublient de me
dire bonjour à moi t longt temps je vais
essayer de laisser un petit peu à à la
maison pour que qu'elle qu'elle
comprenne que ce sera pas chaque jour
qu'il y aura des fois où on pourra pas
dans l'équipe ça a ouvert peut-être
d'autres personnes qui parle maintenant
plus depuis que des est là ouais c'estàd
queon on est on est déjà dans une équipe
qui qui fonctionne bien mais c'est vrai
que ça fait un petit un petit truc en
plus ça fait un je sais pas oui comme
une petite mascotte un petit bien encore
dans dans l'équipe tu lâches pas le
morceau moi non plus dés hein je lâch
pas le
[Musique]
morceau
d D